have you been reading anything about the
depression anything about FDR you know I
have actually I was there's a there's a
new book out about FDR's first hundred
days
hi I'm Michael Moynihan for recent TV
the American economy is in crisis and
Barack Obama has promised to change
Washington but some of those closest to
Obama and some of his loudest media
cheerleaders are advising him to look
backwards towards FDR's New Deal for
inspiration the idea of a new New Deal
has crossed the lips of countless
Democrats in the past six months as
Massachusetts congressman Jim McGovern
recently said I think we could be on the
edge of an era in this country a bold
dramatic change equal to the Great
Society and the New Deal an aid close to
Obama told New York Magazine that a lot
of people around Barack are reading
books about FDR's first hundred days a
kind of New Deal mania has gripped the
pundit class your book is the defining
moment FDR's hundred days and the
triumph of hope no I want him to call
for something like a new New Deal
but what if everything we think we know
about the New Deal is wrong what if
FDR's massive intervention to the
American economy actually prolonged the
Great Depression for something to
restore our confidence our hope our
courage without jobs we had no money as
popular myth hazard it was Keynesian
economics that saved America from the
depression delivering a wounded country
from total disaster people to the
breadline anxiously we waited waited for
some sign of better days
then came the federal government's work
program one by one it took us out of it
was that the New Deal say its defenders
America would have spiraled even deeper
into economic crisis the faces filled
with hope and happiness for now we work
again people lived through the
oppression said Roosevelt saved us and
it's just a very closely held at the
heart view that's UCLA economics
professor Leo hang an author along with
his colleague Harold Cole of a study
demonstrating that FDR's New Deal
policies actually prolonged the
depression by seven years the National
Industrial Recovery Act which was passed
in 1933 allowed firms to Kalu's so for
example if you and I are in the auto
industry General Motors and Ford the
government allow us to say okay we'll
have a minimum price you don't undercut
me I won't undercut you that leads to
higher profits and we
do that provided that we raised wages
for our workers substantially and that's
exactly what happened
when you increase monopolies and you
increase the wage above the normal wage
you're going to have less output and
less employment we didn't really have
any recovery I mean unemployment
remained 15 18 percent throughout the
1930s so there is this vlog view I think
people are beginning to pick up on that
so if the bold persistent
experimentation of the New Deal wasn't
the economic panacea of popular myth
just what should FDR have done in 1933
according to Ohanyan and coal if FDR had
loosened the money supply avoided the
rigid fixing of wages and prices and
instead let market forces work the
economy would have restarted itself much
sooner in other words had the government
not intervened in such a massive way say
Ohanian and coal the recovery would have
been very rapid and the economic slump
would have ended as early as 1936
instead the depression by most estimates
lasted until 1943 the economy is
officially in recession and it looks
like we're in for a long slow road to
recovery but our situation is hardly
analogous to the Great Depression so is
a new New Deal really what we need right
now especially if it works like the old
New Deal did for recent TV I'm Michael
Moynihan
you're talking about spreading the
wealth around she did well first
announced what he did and Obama says
that's his man realization of wealth sir
step in it anytime you build a road